[Musik]
ein Diplom für eine neue
[Applaus]
Zukunft das sind die ersten Abgänger
einer kleinen Hotelfachschule in Ruanda
gegründet von der Schweizerin
Helfenberger weiß ich warum ich wier
mache und um jede Fran bitte dass das
machbar ma dass die jung Profession
Karriere
ist
möglich ich Millionär kan einfach mit
mit viel Passion und Herz bewegen viel
Leidenschaft haben auch diese jungen
Schweizerinnen Jackie Helfenberger hat
die Z bckerlehrlinge für einen Austausch
nach Ruanda gebracht denn in Zukunft
will sie an ihrer Schule auch bcker
[Musik]
ausbilden
Randa ist ihre zweite Heimat und helfen
ihre Passion längst hat sie ihr Herz
kleine Land im Herzen Afrikas
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
[Applaus]
verschenktum TR sie zum mal randischen
Boden ist das für
dich also jetzt immer mehr ich f mich
wirklich ist mega
schön Jackie Helfenberger pendelt seit Z
Jahren zwischen der Schweiz und Rwanda
mit ihrem sangira Hilfswerk will sie
hier die Berufsbildung
fördern jahrelang führte sie ein
sprachreisebüro doch dann kam die
Pandemie und zwang die Branche in die
Knie sie sattelte um und nutzt heute
ihre Erfahrung und ihr Netzwerk für
Entwicklungszusammenarbeit ja jetzt bin
ich gerade im wachsal jetzt der R jetzt
bin ich da jetzt randis Telefon Führer
und fang dann
alle Termine hallo ich bin da wie mor
treffen und dann fang das alles
auflutsche automatisch also von dem her
bin ich sehr Glassen worden und es kommt
immer gut Ruanda will ein Tourismusland
werden statt an den Völkermord von
1994 soll man an Gorillas und unberührte
Natur denken fast eine Million tuzis
wurden damals abgeschlachtet nicht
zuletzt deshalb fehlt dem Land heute
eine ganze Generation Menschen und damit
auch
fachkräfte0
der randerinnen und Rand sind unter 15
Berufsbildung ist deshalb heute
besonders gefragt wir besuchen einen der
damals das Land verließ und später
zurückkehrte das sind
cakeformen und für den Valentinstag
haben wir die Herzen seit Olivier
sogokuru zurück ist aus Belgien betreibt
er in Kigali eine
Bäckerei hier soll ein Teil der
Schweizer Bäckerinnen nächste Woche
Kuchen und Brote backen
ah meine
Wasserwage das hier ist eine
Zukunftsidee ich brauche irgendwann
einen neuen
Ofen den machen sie selber den mache ich
selber aber den Brenner hole ich
vielleicht aus
Belgien das muss einer sein wie bei dem
drin ich brauche nur den
brenn wenn das alles schön aufgemacht
ist wird das
gut wir kommen dann den Kuchen
probieren wenn man etwas nicht zur Hand
hat wissen wir uns immer zu helfen das
müssen wir
halt wer hier weiterkommen will muss
erfinderisch sein das werden auch die
angehenden Bäckerinnen aus der Schweiz
bald
erfahren noch bleiben drei Tage bis zur
Ankunft der zehn Lernenden Jackie und
ihr lokales Team haben noch viel zu
tun wir brauchen
9 10 11
12 13
im es hilft der Kreativität nicht alles
im Detail zu planen ich muss noch meach
auf
vorbereen du bist hier in einem Land in
dem man Englisch Kini Ruanda und
Französisch
spricht du aber repräsentierst die
deutsche
Sprache ich schlage vor du machst eine
Mischung aus
allem und schaffst dadurch eine neue
Kultur
die für die Zukunft Afrikas
steht ich finde das eine gute Idee die
Sprachen zu mischen ich mag sprachen
sehr das repräsentiert mich
gut was
istich ich bin Bruck ich se mich aus
Bruck zwischen de beide Kultur und iches
einfach riesen Potenzial da was wir Kön
lernen vor der Rander und
randerin und was was sie lernen z.B wenn
es um die Rolle der Frauen geht
nirgendwo in Afrika gibt es mehr Frauen
in Führungspositionen eine Folge des
Völkermordes bei dem überwiegend Männer
ums Leben kamen in der Frauenförderung
könne die Schweiz von Ruanda lernen
vielleicht mit einer
Frauenquote es einfach s que oder
bevorzugig zum change starten sehr
brutal
passiertüber viel
Frauen ja und jetzt hab 60% per verfass
in der regier
40%os die machen tolle Job und mir der
Schwiz s 5% also W ich sag Frau auf
Ruanda und L was da was da Frau
[Musik]
[Applaus]
erleichet eine dieser erfolgreichen
Geschäftsfrauen Ruandas will Jackie
heute
[Musik]
treffen grace Grace niria
barinda die beiden kennen sich schon
lange sie sind Freundinnen
geworden Grace betreibt am Rande der
Stadt eine Schneiderei in der sie Frauen
aus Ruanda und dem benachbarten Burundi
beschäftigt sie will diesen damit eine
Zukunft
[Musik]
ermöglichen hier lässtckie traditionelle
Kleid nähen für die große Diplomfeier
die Ende der Woche
ansteht als junge Frau hat Grace den
Völkermord von Randa 1994 erlebt und
überlebt die Wunden sind bis heute nicht
verhalt darüber reden sei wichtig und
helfe sagt
sie heute können wir wie Schwestern
zusammenarbeiten
wie ist das für Sie darüber zu
reden für mich ist das
okay es ist nicht mehr
schwer bevor ich denen nicht vergeben
hatte war es nicht einfach aber langsam
konnte mein Herz
heilen bevor dein Herz nicht geheilt ist
ist es schwierig mit jemandem
zusammenzuarbeiten der deine Familie
getötet
hat das war nicht einfach aber aber
heute ist es
gut der Völkermord bleibt aber ein
heikles Thema dass man kaum beim ersten
Gespräch
anspricht wir haben schonst zwei dr
troffen und dann hab ich gemerkt sie sie
offen zum über das reden
und dann hab ich auch gewagt Frage
stellen will ich hab auch schon viel
eine Frage gestellt aber dann hab ich
gemerkt ich muss auch antworte könen
verdauen will wenn man Vertrauen hat
dann zu dann D sie einzähl aber das sind
mE so schlimme
geschichtet man dann einige Tag dann ich
auch aufört Frage stellen einfach so
viel dass
ich
Verdau wir sind alle Ruanda sprechen die
gleiche Sprache warum sollten wir uns
umbringen ich merke es gibt viele Taben
in diesem Land derölkermord ist eines
darf die ruppen der Hutus und tuzis
nicht mehr beim Namen nennen offiziell
gibt es nur noch
Ruanda wie schnell die Emotionen beim
Thema völkomort trotz alledem auch heute
noch hochgehen merken wir bei unserem
nächsten Treffen wir fahren an einen Ort
der wie kaum ein anderer an den Genozid
erinnert das Hotel de milkolin in Kigali
es ist der Ausgangspunkt für den
berühmten Film Hotel Ruanda dank eines
mutigen Hoteldirektors haben hier 1200
tutis die Greultaten der Hutus überlebt
hier hat Jackie eine Verabredung mit
einem Schweizer der lange für eine
Entwicklungsbank in Ruanda arbeitete und
jetzt als Tourist da
ist und wie fühlt sich so noch 40 Jahr
wieder da sie fast 40 Jahr ja sind
ziemlich genau 40 Jahr es sind Gemisch
die Gefühl wenn Du so direkt frag wie s
anfühlt oder auf der S
Stadt
kennt berv hat große Fragezeichen wie
nachhaltig das wirtschaftsbom sei und
legt den Finger auf einen wunden Punkt
die Schere zwischen Arm und
Reich
Stra ich in Randa wie vor 40 Jahr
eigentlich V der
Armut ich jetzt Gefühl so V Land ist
sehr wenig bis n g als ich da
Skepsis da wirklich nachhaltig gemacht h
respektive jetztchtig ma Jackies Partner
bobito kränkt diese Sicht er vertritt
die Meinung sein Land sei im
Aufbruch siehst du nicht dass die
Entwicklung da
ist s nicht alle aber ichon Statistik wo
wir jetzt sind also
entschuldigungn nur blind sein wenn man
diese Jackie Helfenberger versucht zu
schlichten und lenkt zurück zu ihrem
Thema der Bildung ich danke einfach mit
de Mittel wo sie Hand hat sie schon
schon vieles gemacht aber aber drum sind
wir ja da und hat die Schul aufbaut oder
die hotelleries Schu jetzt in jameke und
ich danke du über
se aber Zugpferd ist K wo ich denke über
kurz oder lang zieht das zit das alle
mit Jackies schlichten hilft nicht vom
Wirtschaftsboom kommt man auf den
Genozid und schließlich auf die bis
heute umstrittene Rolle der
internationalen Entwicklungshilfe das
Gespräch eskaliert wir müssen die Kamera
ausschalten das Treffen macht mir
deutlich auch bald 30 Jahre danach
bleiben viele Fragen
offen ein neuer Tag beginnt die
bckerlehrlinge aus der Schweiz sollen
heute in Kigali
landen längst ist der Flieger da doch
von den zehn Bäckerinnen keine
Spur die
oder
ja immer
ja viel aber mir hat Lim aber im Moment
ged Vers
jetzt auch Jackie helfenbergers Partner
bobito wird langsam nervös er versucht
seine Beziehungen spielen zu
lassen Hallo die Bäckerinnen hängen am
Zoll fest
was ist jetzt passiert wir haben da viel
Schuhe Schuh
und Wert WIS von de Schuh jeder Koffer
hat sch drin und wir haben zw
so Zertifikat dass es für z aber sie
wierö mit
Ruanda nach
Ruanda tatsächlich wirkt der Anruf
wundercha
endlich hat's
geklappt hallo wie schon
wieder
wow alle sind da ich bin zufed sind alle
gesund
[Gelächter]
h lang
[Musik]
die zehn Lernenden sind da und mit ihen
Berge von Gepäck nicht nur Schuhe
sondern auch Backutensilien und
Zutaten Randa wird nun für einen Monat
ihre neue Heimat sein die jungen Frauen
sind alle zum ersten Mal in Afrika junge
Bäcker haben sich keine interessiert für
den
Austausch das Abenteuer beginnt am
nächsten Morgen mit dem Besuch eines
lokalen Marktes
die Lernenden sollen herausfinden welche
Zutaten man hier kaufen kann und welche
nicht damit Sie auch wissen welche
Rezepte sich später überhaupt umsetzen
lassen ihr aufentthalt in Rwanda wird
getragen von einer Schweizer Stiftung
Ziel ist der Austausch von Wissen beide
Seiten sollen am Ende von der anderen
profitieren
können
[Musik]
was ist
es so ja ja
GoW es dauert nicht lange und schon
erfasst sie das randische Shoppingfieber
[Musik]
das sind die
Tees
tomato Frücht sehr
feinsfrucht nein
danke ich habe das schon mal probiert
und mag es nicht
will Druck
überflutet von neuen Eindrücken
verlassen sie den Markt die Arbeit
ruft die Lernenden sollen ein erstes Mal
ihre Berufskenntnisse weitergeben und
werden dazu in zwei lokale
Bäckereibetriebe
aufgeteilt
Sache zusammen mit ihren ruandischen
Kolleginnen sollen sie heute Kuchen und
Brote backen die übermorgen an der
Diplomfeier von Jackie helfenbergers
Schule aufgetischt
werdenelleicht wist es schon wir haben
die Hotelfachschule mit 120
Studierenden und wir müssen 300 Gäste
verköstigen Ziel ist also dass wir ganz
viel Brot und Kuchen produzieren für die
Leute dort in
yamasheke die zweite Gruppe arbeitet in
einer modernen schaubäckerei eines
großen
Supermarktes hier fehlt an
nichts kannst du mir zeigen
wie die handriffe zu Hause diese Gruppe
stellt die sandwichbrote für die
Diplomfeier
her
okay Jackie nutzt die Zeit für ein
weiteres Treffen es geht dabei um ihre
Tourismusschule die sie vor zwei Jahren
im Süden des Landes ins Leben gerufen
hat in zwei Tagen werden dort die ersten
120 Hotelangestellten diplomiert damit
alles seine Richtigkeit hat trifft sich
Jackie Helfenberger heute mit der
Ministerin für Berufsbildung denn noch
immer fehlt die offizielle
Akkreditierung der
Schule unser Team hat nun alle
Unterlagen
eingereicht der Registrierungsprozess
läuft also der zweite Lehrgang mit etwa
100 Studierenden startet gerade die
erste Gruppe wird am 13 juli
diplomiert das ist jetzt ger wichtiges
Gespräch oder
ja ja doch doch es ist gut zum wiüssen
wer jetzt schon Bescheid weiß über die
sangira Schuh Ineke und wer noch nicht
genau Bescheid weiß also es WIS schon
viel Bescheid aber es hat noch ein paar
Lücke und ein paar puelstein zum Füllen
aber das geh gut aus dass jetzt die
akkreditiere komm ja das geh gut aus
ja in der modernen schaubäckerei läuft
derweil alles wie am Schnürchen noch
nicht
gut die ersten googlehöpfe sind
fertig sie sehen so aus wie in der
Schweiz bei der anderen Gruppe hingegen
geht's noch etwas gemütlicher zu und her
oh mein
[Gelächter]
Gott
we jetzt der Hand
das lel und gefunden warum haben wir
Grillzange
gefunden mit der
ja grillzangen statt Löffel ein Gasherd
ohne Gas not macht erfinderisch was ma
jetzt da der Butter Gas
und dann auch noch ein Ofen voller
Überraschungen da ist noch Brot
[Gelächter]
drin dieerinnen aus der Schweiz lassen
sich nicht Ruhe
bringen sie nutzen die Zeit zum
Austausch von Rezepten wie z.B einer
rüheblittorte die schnellwachsende
Mittelschicht in der Hauptstadt Kigali
verlangt immer mehr nach Brot und
Backwaren einen Monat werden die jungen
Schweizerinnen in Ruanda sein sie kommen
von überall her aus der Schweiz und
haben für diesen Austausch zum Teil auch
Ferien
hergegeben im Gespräch mit ihren
randischen Kolleginnen lernen Sie dass
man Rosinen nicht überall auf der Welt
[Gelächter]
kennt immer noch nicht sie alle haben
sich für den Austausch entschieden um
ihr Wissen weiterzugeben und selber von
der fremden Kultur etwas
[Musik]
mitzunehmen
und sei es nur das Improvisieren z.B
wenn es um den Abwasch
geht gut Ding will Weile haben nach
zweieinhalb Stunden ist es endlich
soweit g wie normale also gut
ja D s sehr
wer wer B
sind aber ich glaub das ist
gut und langsam erschließt sich mir auch
der Grund warum bcker Olivier einen
neuen Ofen bauen
will zum Abschluss des Tages der
verdiente Apero in gediegener
Atmosphäre ein bisschen Großstadt bevor
es morgen weitergeht aufs Land
die Reise beginnt im Stau von
Kigali bevor sie uns immer weiter hinauf
ins Grüne
führt bald wir klar warum Ruanda auch
das Land der 1000 Hügel oder die Schweiz
Afrikas genannt wird
8 Stunden Fahrt führen uns durch
abgelegene
[Applaus]
Dörfer und einmal quer durch den
Dschungel
entlang der Grenze
berundis vorbeiern
[Musik]
Affen und
verunfallten
lastwagena das
ein kurzer Fotostop in den berühmten
[Musik]
Teeplantagen und dann endlich kommt der
kivosee in
Sichtweite gerade als die Sonne hinter
denü des Kongos verschwindet erreichen
wir endlich das
zielus und dann gehen wir nachher zum
Essen wenn wir alles ausgepackt haben
das finde ich gut und dann beginnt der
Tag auf den alle schon lange
hingearbeitet
haben die ersten Tourismusfachleute von
Jackie helfenbergers Schule werden
diplomiert auf dem Festgelände laufen
die letzten
Vorbereitungen mehrere us den höchsten
Rängen von Regierung und Militär werden
erwartet zur gleichen Zeit steigt in den
Räumlichkeiten der Tourismusschule die
Nervosität jackie hat alle Hände voll zu
[Musik]
tun
die aus der Schweiz müssen noch verteilt
werden nebenan stürzen sich die
Diplomanten in ihre
ren auch die Bäckerinnen sind schon
lange wieder an der Arbeit es braucht
noch mehr Brote damit es für alle Gäste
reicht
die lange sandwi Fülle BR hab sch
vorbereitet fülle mit Avocado Tomate
Schinken genau Organisation
schwiigklichkeit dann hab
materialine
gemacht zwar
länger aberhr gut funktioniert
gut mit jetzt da ja ich find für dass
wir sie da gemacht haben und sie die
Teigmaschine gemacht haben jetzt sehr
schö
ge auf dem Festgelände sitzen die Eltern
und Verwandten längst auf ihren
Plätzen und die Band spielt sich schon
mal
ein nebenan begrüßt Jackie Helfenberger
im Schatten der Bäume alle VIP
Gäste
der malik ist der Honorarkonsul für
Randa in Tschechien
Tchechien
an ist Bürgermeisterin von
yamek
Bürgermeister Bürgermeister
[Musik]
Commander
von der
richard ist der
[Musik]
koloneluigungit
und diese Leute zu kennen ist wichtig
nicht es ist wichtig diese Leute zu
kennen wir arbeiten Hand in Hand es ist
wichtig nicht nur
füreke davon profitiert die ganze
Hotelindustrie
randas die richtigen Menschen zu kennen
hilft auch in
Ruanda auf dem Papier ist das Land zwar
eine Demokratie de facto liegt die macht
aber seit dem Genozid in den Händen
einer einzigen Partei stramm unterstützt
vom Militär das immer und überall
sichtbar ist natürlich auch wenn
gefeiert
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wird
[Applaus]
all diese jungen Menschen erhalten heute
ihr Diplom als
Hotelfachkräfte ne Monate haben sie
gelernt wie man Gäste begrüßt Betten
macht kocht oder Essen
serviert sieus
ärlichenen
helfenbergers sangir Stiftung umsonst
eine Ausbildung
erhalten von den 120 Abgängern haben
alle einen Arbeitsvertrag mit einem
Hotel unterzeichnet und halten damit ein
Ticket für eine bessere Zukunft in der
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
[Applaus]
Hand
kubaanourugo ich gratuliere den
Studierenden für die harte Arbeit die
Sie geleistet
haben
ich weiß jetzt auch wofür ich so hart
gearbeitet habe dieser wunderschöne
Moment gibt mir sehr viel
zurück herzlichen
[Applaus]
Dank schon in wenigen
[Musik]
tagentellerule nch
le wird zurück in die Schweiz reisen um
weiter für ihr Herzensprojekt zu
sammeln das rauschende Fest dauert noch
bis tief in die
Nacht und vereint die lernwilligen aus
zwei
[Musik]
[Applaus]
Kontinenten
[Musik]
मुها